الأمر بسيط بالنسبة لي ، كندا بحاجة إلى المزيد من
الأشخاص ، يفهم الكنديون الحاجة إلى
الاستمرار في زيادة عدد السكان لدينا إذا كنا سنلبي
احتياجات القوى
العاملة إذا أردنا إعادة التوازن إلى
اتجاه ديموغرافي مثير للقلق وإذا
كنا سنستمر  لم شمل العائلات
[موسيقى]
يركز الأجانب على النمو
الاقتصادي وبحلول السنة الثالثة من هذه الخطة ،
سيتم قبول 60 بالمائة من المهاجرين الجدد
ضمن فئات الهجرة الاقتصادية
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية
، ستوفر الآلية الجديدة في نظام الهجرة لدينا
أكثر
طريقة ذكية ومرنة لمطابقة معايير الاختيار الخاصة بنا
مع ضغوط نقص العمالة المحددة
ومعالجة الفرص الإستراتيجية من
خلال جذب القادمين الجدد
بالمهارات المطلوبة
في كندا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]